china's defense minister wei feng ha has
warned that any attempt to bring about
taiwan's independence will trigger a
fight to the end he spoke at a regional
security forum in singapore general wei
accused the united states of pursuing an
indo-pacific strategy bound to lead to
confrontation he said china's
relationship with the u.s was at a
critical juncture and that it was up to
washington to improve ties
at asia's most important security summit
in singapore a threat of war
if anyone dares to split taiwan from
china
the chinese military will fight at all
costs to smash any secessionist attempt
and will resolutely safeguard national
sovereignty and territorial integrity
that warning followed a meeting between
superpower defense ministers china's
weifeng her
and lloyd austin of the u.s
tensions between beijing and washington
over the self-governing island of taiwan
have soared in recent months
frequent incursions by the chinese air
force into taiwan's air defense zone
have angered the biden administration
we've witnessed a steady increase
in provocative and destabilizing
military activity near taiwan
and we remain focused on maintaining
peace
stability and the status quo
across across the taiwan strait
but the prc's
moves threaten to undermine security and
stability
and prosperity in the indo-pacific
last month president joe biden announced
that washington would defend taiwan
should china attack
provoking an angry rebuke from beijing
but the white house has since walked
back those statements
part of a deliberate policy of vagueness
on taiwan known as strategic ambiguity
for the small island living in the
shadow of its increasingly assertive
neighbor
that ambiguity provides little comfort
you